i've always loved and respected
soulsborne games but
mother
i've never actually played a soulsborne
game plus on top of that soulsborne
games reward patience and persistence
[Music]
two traits that i've never really had in
abundance
yet i've always had respect for them
[ __ ]
but i was just never really able to show
it
that is until today because i work at
gamesbot now it's my job to play games
plus everyone at gamespot is currently
excited for fromsoft's upcoming elden
ring so why not use it as an excuse to
play a game that i've always wanted to
play so i pitched this video to my boss
and
heaven helper she said yes oh also
before we get much further i know that
this is technically a game of thrones
cosplay and that is actually subzero
sword gamespot doesn't give me a budget
for this this is what i've got i'm
trying but my desire to play dark souls
also has an ulterior motive i'm actually
currently new to the gamespot team and
now i kind of get to call people that
i've looked up to for my entire career
co-workers
and let me tell you it's kind of a
little bit intimidating how could i ever
measure up to these folks that i now
work with
okay kurt i can measure up to kurt but
the rest of these folks
i constantly feel a need to prove myself
that i have a right to be on this team
and dark souls is the way that i can
prove that
hell i've changed my gender i bet i can
beat dark souls i mean being trans is
like the dark souls of
so i snagged myself a copy of dark souls
remastered and i'm going to hunker down
and play nothing else until i beat this
game and i'm going to chronicle each day
of my journey with this game and record
myself as i do so all right my
dark souls journey begins
now
and after i
close kenna i'm also not going to look
up any help online because this is a
test of my ability and my ability alone
however to get me started i did ask some
of my co-workers to send me videos of
encouragement and i watched one of them
at the start of each and every play
session so as i settled into my quest
with my standard equipment of mountain
dew doritos and a banjo-kazooie plush
doll for comfort i played the first
video
first off congratulations you're now
entering the realm of true
gameree
if uh that's a thing and that's not a
thing
um that's that's gatekeepy you're not a
true gamer just because you played a
souls game you're just cooler than
everyone else that's also messed up
and not true you're fine just the way
you are despite whatever games you play
mm-hmm
we weren't off to a good start with
kurt's video clearly he didn't
understand that dark souls was meant to
test me for me to prove myself that's
don't don't
don't listen to a word i said don't
worry kurt i never do
as i began my journey through the undead
asylum the first section of the game i
was immediately struck by a surprise
there were actually instructions written
onto the ground of the game from
everything i had heard dark souls was a
series that didn't tutorialize itself to
the player so i had my expectations
immediately confronted which was a
little bit shocking maybe this game
wasn't going to be as hard as i thought
and this continued because as i pressed
on and began to explore the area i was
surprised by how peaceful it all
oh hello
hi friend oh god
okay
yeah
so that was my first encounter with how
dark souls loves to throw situations at
you unexpectedly that you are nowhere
near prepared for there was no way i was
ready to beat this massive dude who kind
of looked like me when i wake up on a
sunday morning yet i quickly learned
that this was actually intentional by
the game as i soon found an escape and
began to explore the area around me in
order to get better equipment and
practice before returning to my fugly
friend over the next 20 minutes i slowly
explored as i got more comfortable with
the slow yet precise mechanics and
pacing of the controls and built up my
souls in order to level up i'm loving
kicking these bodies of brown
finally though i was ready to take on
the boss and i earned my damn victory
yeah
take it right in your stupid belly face
it was an incredibly satisfying routine
and one which was just a microcosm of
the entirety of the game before me
though i had yet to learn it still i
took satisfaction in my minor victory if
only i knew how minor it really was i've
got some humanity
ah i was so innocent then from there i
met a giant bird and got whisked away to
the game's main area and was truly set
loose in the kingdom of lordran here
again i was somewhat shocked at how open
this world was and i quickly explored
and ran into a nearby graveyard because
i thought that that was the coolest
place to be
and then i got repeatedly destroyed by
skeletons
damn freaking jerks yet something
strange happened here too despite these
skeletons being clearly more powerful
than i due to the preciseness and
methodical give and take between
attacking blocking a movement that the
game's combat supported i thought i was
actually intended to beat these guys i
mean it felt possible and that the only
barrier was my skill with the game even
though i kept dying every single damn
time that i took them on
it actually took me 30 minutes to
realize that while i could go that way
there was actually a much more intended
and better path for me to take and it
was moments like this that had me start
to understand that dark souls was not a
game about direct restrictions it
allowed you to go anywhere you wished
but it softly guided you through failure
which took me to undead burg and it was
here where i started to get a true vibe
for dark souls i was able to finally
fully explore an area and feel a sense
of progression as i beat new enemies and
started to level up even if i died i
felt renewed confidence to pick up and
keep going and if you return to where
you died you got all your souls earned
back which seemed fair to me and at this
point in the game i had never lost a
single soul so instead of being scared
at every encounter and corner like i had
been before i started to feel confident
as i moved forward in fact i had too
much confidence because that's when i
met this
no
god damn it
ah
son of a [ __ ] this night felt like my
first real challenge in the game and he
felt like he was supposed to be easy he
was just a dude hanging out in a corner
and yet i couldn't beat him i kept
trying over and over and over and over
and over and over and over again come on
get up
come on come on
it was this moment that made me hate
everything i hated this guy i hated this
game so [ __ ] that night
[ __ ]
finally after three hours of trying i
just cave up and decided to just move on
and try fighting the boss cause
why not find a new way to lose again
instead of doing the same thing over and
over again
but then
something strange happened
i actually beat the boss
on the first try and i don't think i
have ever felt better in my life
i did a thing
oh and then he tells you victor
being honest i was actually dealing with
a few personal things the day that i
started out this game so
this moment kind of got to me
emotionally
[Music]
i legitimately can't tell you how much i
needed that i feel like i'm going to cry
a little bit because i legitimately
needed that i needed
something to tell me
that i accomplished something today
after so much shittiness both in the
game and in my personal life that day
having a win
actually kind of broke me a bit
that was like 10 times easier than
everything i've been doing for the past
two hours
and it's the boss i hate this game i
hate it
i want to cry and yet i also now wish to
keep going i hate everything that this
game does to me
hello jesse it's me you're all pal tam
as someone who's played dark souls for
the first time many times
i've got a bit of advice for you it's
actually a rhyme that i told myself the
rhyme goes
bonfire lit
bonfire set that'll keep you from
forgetting to do something very
important every time you find a bonfire
beyond that
patience perseverance
and make sure you read those item
descriptions they're important before i
began the day i was already having a
strange feeling jumping back into the
game after i put down the game yesterday
and went about my normal evening stuff
that i do
i started to realize that i kept
thinking about the game and how much i
wanted to get back to it like how much i
couldn't
wait for today to start so i could just
pick it back up and just dive back in
and just like
hopefully figure out how to get just a
little bit further because i was just so
curious about what's
further
in this world that i could discover and
what i wanted to do something i did not
expect going into my second day playing
this game and what's even more
interesting is that starting on day two
i actually caked walk through the entire
next area the stuff that had frustrated
me at the end of the last day after just
a good night's rest and fresh eyes
became easy became second nature now i
have a theory about that i feel like i
had built up so much confidence at the
beginning of my first day that it
actually started to become
overconfidence in the game and
eventually that overconfidence came
crashing down around me in true dark
souls fashion
right there
that constant push and pull of emotions
distracted me but coming into a new day
with my emotions reset i began to learn
that not only was this game a battle
with monsters mechanics and control
schemes
that it was actually a dance with your
own emotions how the entire game was a
meditation
on letting go
not that i didn't feel the lovely lovely
rush of endorphins whenever i beat a
boss though after about two hours of
trying to beat those damn bell gargoyles
i was nearly doing a freaking jig in my
living room when i finally destroyed
them
[Music]
yes
victory achieved
boom
this i would come to understand is the
ballet of dark souls the push and pull
between your skill and your own emotions
losing but learning in each loss even if
you lose all your souls and in-game
markers of progress you're conditioning
yourself up here so from beating the
bell gargoyles for the next few hours i
just progressed further and further into
the game coming to this emotional
understanding and this by the way is an
excellent time for me to mention how
much i just adore how this game is built
i've since discovered how much discourse
there is around dark souls and its
design but as someone coming into a
decades old game in 2022 i was shocked
by how meticulous the actual world
design of this game was how the world
all felt continuous interconnected and
purposeful like for example how you can
see different areas of the game from
other sections of the world how the land
masses all felt like it made sense
within their own universe and how it all
felt connected to each other despite it
not making any real sense if you think
about it for example you can discover
that the lowest point in the entire game
world is an underground lake which is
actually technically underneath a bed of
fire now that makes no sense by our
metric of how geography works but in
dark souls it has this
weird ring of truth to it and makes the
world feel unique and yet truly alive
and i just adored it not only that but
the world and its hidden faults and
foibles become etched onto your brain
like for example this moment which
pissed me right off when i fell off a
damn underwater cliff that you can't
even see during the middle of a freaking
boss battle
[Music]
that is [ __ ]
like how the hell are you supposed to
know that there's a damn underwater
cliff that insta kills you when you're
fighting this freaking hydra thing but
the truth is
you're not supposed to know it at least
not the first time but once you figure
it out
now you know for next time
the game is all about learning through
failure most games today teach you
through success setting up minor
challenges to teach you how to
eventually take on larger ones for
example you'll learn a new skill or get
a new ability and then the game will
give you an easy challenge to test that
ability then it will give you a harder
one than a harder one all meant to have
you succeed in incremental ways along
the way and dark souls wants you to
learn at that exact same pace but by
making you fail to get there instead
oh no
ah what the [ __ ] is that thing and that
is the goddamn awful and wonderful at
the same time
yes
victoria oh god that says blighttown i
know what that is
okay by the end of day two i had faced
and beaten several bosses and even got
through the infamous blighttown and by
the way here's my hot take here
blighttown it's not as bad as its
reputation gives it though i will say
[ __ ] those mosquitoes they can go right
to hell or you know whatever the hell
equivalent is in dark souls all of this
i learned on my second day of playing
with dark souls and as i progressed
through the game i had great success
and yet
i still felt that something was missing
but i wasn't really sure what it was yet
you got this jesse you can beat the
dark souls boss
despite how vague evan's encouragement
was little did i know
how much i would need it today because
both day three and day four could
probably best be described as the days
that i got my ass handed to me
god [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ]
no no
[Applause]
[ __ ] camera [ __ ] you camera
[ __ ] this camera
this fight [ __ ] [ __ ] this game
um i just i just
yeah so on day three i faced off against
the wolf sif and on day four i faced off
against those bosses entwined smoe and
ornstein huh i made a rhyme
those bosses still suck though both of
these boss battles took me hours upon
hours of attempts to beat stiff kept
jumping around the damn battlefield with
her cute little puppy sword killing me
over and over and over again oh he
looked cool poppy horn disordered his
mouth
oh it was a cool baby oh god which was
admittedly adorable but freaking
frustrating while these two timing jerks
kept beating the ever loving crap out of
me why do you bum brush over and over
again getting too teamed at least in
this way is not fun at all even worse
though i got sucked into that most
dangerous of gamer compulsions the one
more try i'm sure for every single one
of us gamers we've all had this
experience at one level or another but i
was up until four in the morning both
nights when i intended to get to bed by
midnight because i kept trying to beat
these bosses just one more time alright
that's a whole thing
uh
in fact because i was up so late one
night i actually missed our normal
tuesday 9 am morning meeting which
thankfully though got cancelled so no
one found out
until right now uh lucy uh this is just
a creative flourish i totally didn't
sleep through the meeting
but back to the bosses my frustration
got so bad and so defined me that i had
to remember what i had taught myself all
the way back on day one
that i needed to release my frustration
in fact i eventually learned to use my
time running back to the boss arena
between attempts as moments of
meditation and breathing to get myself
back into the zone again
okay
before i would end up inevitably
screaming again [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you
in fact this boss battle got so
frustrating i did something that i said
i wouldn't do i looked up help online i
got online and tried to find strategies
on how to beat these two bosses but to
be honest i actually didn't find any
useful strategies like i hoped because i
had already figured out most of them
but what i didn't end up finding was
much more helpful i found message boards
and reddit posts and youtube videos all
from people sharing their own
frustration at these bosses and so while
i knew i was frustrated i
for the first time
didn't feel alone in that
i realized this feeling that i was
having
was part of the experience that everyone
had had with this game this was the
experience of dark souls
and so
i kept pressing on and finally
finally i beat those [ __ ] and
while sif's defeat was
honestly goddamn heartbreaking because
that poor puffer's getting so sad at the
end of her boss battle that i just felt
really bad killing her oh this is so sad
why would i do this
i wanted to kill you so badly that it
makes me just really sad to kill you
[Music]
i hate this game so
much but with smo and ornstein oh i
cannot tell you how good it felt to
watch these [ __ ] die
oh
[Music]
god it is four in the morning and i've
finally beaten this boss and i can just
feel this tension
that i've had in my chest for the past
four or five hours playing this
[ __ ] thing
just slowly like
releasing
oh my god
but sitting there at four in the morning
i finally realized what was missing
i had no one to share this with i live
alone and i had told myself that i would
do this entire dark souls battle alone
but
reading those posts from others
made me recognize how much i wish i
could
share my achievement
instead of just
cheering at four in the morning by
myself
[Music]
day five was the first day that i didn't
have any new words of encouragement from
my co-workers
and i felt more alone than ever
yet i kept playing progressing steadily
but i felt the sense of purposelessness
who was i really doing this for
i thought when i started this journey
that i could do it all by myself that
the purpose was to test my skill
but
now
that reason felt empty
hollow
i felt
hollow
i decided that night to play dark souls
on stream for the first time with a
friend of mine and my chat
and i was so shocked to find how many
people were just excited that i was
playing dark souls for the first time
throughout the entire conversation that
i had with my friend in the chat i heard
stories from people who were so excited
to vicariously experience the game again
through me or people who had never
played it themselves due to
accessibility issues and wanted to hear
my thoughts
even further i got to hear people share
what this game meant to them how it
helped them overcome depression or how
it got them into exploring nietzsche and
philosophy or how obsessed with the lord
that they were and after i got off
stream i had members of my community
send me even more advice on build to my
character or what shields to level up to
help me later in the game and all this
sort of stuff for the first time i felt
the sense of
meaning from this game beyond my own
aggrandizement and that honestly started
to reflect my understanding of the game
itself there is a whole community of
people breaking down the potential
themes and lore of dark souls which
itself is very open to interpretation
but
during my playthrough what i came to
understand was dark souls is about a
world that does not give a damn about
you oh [ __ ] you you're just another
person in this world as opposed to other
games where the second you step out into
them you're the most important person in
the goddamn universe not so with dark
souls lordran does not give a crap about
you and i think that is a large part of
why people give up on this game they get
beaten down and give up because this
game is hard yes but not insurmountable
it teaches you how to play through
failure and requires patience but it
also tells you that this game is not
going to cater itself to you and that
very dynamic that exact feeling is
reflected in the game's story and world
in dark souls your character is an
undead and undead in this universe go
hollow if they give in to the nihilism
of the world if they give up and just
believe that there's no purpose in even
trying anymore it's so easy within
lordran to recognize that it does not
care for you so
why care about yourself yet as you
explore while this world doesn't have
any inherent meaning you find and meet
characters who have their own meaning
and make their own meeting in this world
i have come to this great land the
birthplace of lord gwyn to seek my very
own son
some philosophies and ideas are good
some are bad in fact the main story of
the game revolves around a prophecy that
was just sort of
made up a few hundred years ago by those
in power in this world in order to
convince an undead person like your
player character to eventually sacrifice
themselves to keep the current age of
fire going and keep the age of darkness
the end of this cycle of the world at
bay and while that sounds all well and
good what you ultimately learn is that
hundreds of thousands of undead have
made this exact journey before you and
made the same sacrifice to keep the age
of fire going but no matter what you do
the age of darkness will come
all you can possibly do is kill yourself
to delay it just a little bit longer as
the end of the day you're not important
and you can't change the fate of the
world you were just told by others
making their own meanings for you and
for themselves to sacrifice to find this
bigger meaning for yourself but
ultimately it's purposeless it's
creating stories that benefit themselves
and give themselves meaning and dark
souls is about that exact feeling
it's a game about giving up to the
meaninglessness of the world
or
finding your own meaning
and i realized my original meaning for
playing this game was to prove myself to
show that i was a badass who could
defeat dark souls alone
but that
left me feeling hollow
it wasn't a meaning that actually meant
something to me
instead
i realized what meant something to me
was sharing dark souls with others
that this game was about finding
connection
not improving how good i was and so as i
approached the end of the game i asked
the last person that i ever expected to
ask to join me in beating the final boss
take a deep breath your life can't get
any worse so you might as well just
enjoy this
[ __ ]
yes of all people kurt was there as i
beat the final boss or at least as i
attempted to uh jesse
a really good
game
is to not die
right outside
of the gate of fog
in fact we played for two whole hours
trying to beat this final boss who by
the way is very handsy and while kurt
did give me a lot of support i have
faith all right watch out for the bim
bam boom scoop
yeah no not when it gets handy it's not
nothing compared to the hand
gum become back up oh my god that was a
spicy heel see that's good using that
rock yes oh good yeah yeah yeah yes yes
yes yes uh
yeah i'm just gonna keep saying that
over and over again idiot yes yes yes
back up oh my god
oh
oh my that was good
i actually didn't beat the boss while
kurt was there i literally beat the
final boss on my first try after kurt
logged off
no
no
kurt literally the first time
in fact it was so soon after that he
left that i beat the boss that i was
actually able to call him back to
celebrate with me immediately after it
happened like i was like this is too
perfect if i literally beat it the first
try after kurt hangs up
congratulations
i did it we did it
you did it
i just i
the best thing i could have done was
just [ __ ] off and leave in many regards
that experience epitomizes my dark souls
journey because looking back at that
final boss battle i actually don't
really remember beating him what i do
remember is kurt and i joking as i faced
him and how he and i celebrated right
afterwards we did we did it together i i
didn't do [ __ ] that was all you way to
go boom yes hell's up yes i'm very
pleased with this the part that i did
alone the actual victory achieved that
fades into memory so in the end i loved
every second of this game and
i'm honestly kind of sad that i can't
experience it again
but that being said i may have gotten um
a little obsessed um
just a little bit but the purpose that i
found in dark souls
is about the journey and the meaning we
put into that journey that matters
[Music]
i needed
something to tell me
that i accomplished something today
ryan goes
don't find it
on fire [ __ ] why do you bother us over
and over again
oh he's a cool baby oh god
congratulations i did it we did it
you did it
and also i learned that kurt is weird
like very weird
thank you so much for watching and if
you can't get enough of from software or
dark souls this video is actually part
of a series that we're doing in
anticipation for the upcoming elden ring
from from software so please check out
some of our other videos in that series
such as the wonderful dave klein's look
back at one of the seminal games in from
software's history kingsfield it's a
really awesome video that you should
totally check out but until you do i'm
going to just leave you with this
unedited version of kurt's video that he
told me not to share with anybody so
enjoy okay tips for uh
babies first dark souls
if they say preheat the oven to 350
wait till the beeper goes off to alert
you
that the oven is pre is completely
preheated because if you put the
food in
uh like the cookies
before that time that that beep goes off
and then you you still kind of wave the
like the cook time of like seven minutes
and it it's not going to be the way it
was intended um
take from that what you will don't
listen to a word i've said i don't even
use this video um